et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec alexis poulin directeur et
cofondateur du monde moderne monsieur
poulin bienvenu merci d'être avec nous
alors expliquez nous les enjeux de cette
journée de mobilisation c'est la
septième depuis la première le 5
décembre
oui septième journée de mobilisation 51e
jour de grève l'enjeu c'est de dire que
cette grève n'est pas fini loin de là
alors bien sûr elle est difficile parce
que pour les grévistes c'est une perte
de salaire brut et on ne fait pas de la
grève pour gagner de l'argent et ça
commence à se sentir je pense donc il ya
l'idée du pourrissement
parce que le pouvoir installer cette
stratégie dès le début en disant de
toute façon nous avons le temps nous
nous sommes payés nous avons le droit le
pouvoir et nous pouvons attendre que les
grévistes s'essouffle l'idée c'est de
montrer que cette stratégie ne
fonctionne pas que d'autres secteurs
vont rentrer dans la grève on l'a vu
avec le secteur des incinérateurs les
avocats et d'autres et et de dire que au
delà de deux mesures qui peut y avoir à
faire cette grève la mobilisation reste
au total vous appelez marche aux
flambeaux aussi des moyens d'action qui
sont un peu nouveau vous avez des
happenings aussi dans les gares on a vu
des chorégraphies l'opéra de paris bien
entendu l'idée c'est de se rendre
visibles peut-être faire action
autrement mais continuer la mobilisation
sachant que c'est extrêmement difficile
dans le temps alors le quasi retour à la
normale dans les transports parisiens il
faut le dire on a quand même un peu
l'impression que la mobilisation est en
train de s'essouffler ma le nombre de
crédits ce qui diminue après un mois et
demi d'une grève
on peut le dire intense est ce que cette
baisse de la mobilisation de la
mobilisation ne va pas justement
rassurer l'exécutif évidemment c'est
tout le pari de l'exécutif c'est de se
rassurer de dire que finalement c'est
fini on va passer en force
cette retraite ce que disait jean luc
mélenchon sur ce texte avec les trous
sur la façon dont le débat démocratique
va être mené à l'assemblée
on a vu un sur la loi via la loi de
censure sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
très peu de débat finalement
l'assemblée est devenue un territoire
mort du débat démocratique c'est
malheureux et sur les retraites
l'idée c'est de passer en force c'est à
dire finalement on verra bien on fait
cette conférence sur le financement
et puis après on fera des ordonnances
s'il le faut mais on passera de toute
façon en force puisque ce programme des
vacances c'est d'avoir d'utiliser au
maximum ses cinq ans pour casser un
maximum d'acquis sociaux et de
solidarité dans ce pays alors on a un
exécutif apparemment jusqu'au boutistes
qui veut passer en force comme vous le
dites on a une mobilisation qui
continuait si les deux sont jusqu'au
boutiste l'exécutif et les
intersyndicales
quelle peut être l'issue l'issue de
court terme ce sera une fausse victoire
une victoire à la pyrrhus pour
l'exécutif qui va avoir neutralisé des
syndicats comme l'unsa qui comme la cfdt
une victoire à la pyrrhus aussi sans
doute pour la cgt qui va avoir peut-être
recruter de nouveaux membres et de
nouveaux syndiqués mais sur le long
terme c'est une politique de la terre
brûlée finalement parce que la colère la
contestation le refus du débat
démocratique on l'a vu avec le grand
débat qui a été une une confiscation de
la parole en réalité puisque les cahiers
de doléances n'ont même pas été
numérisés et ils ont été rangés adultes
et nationales de français et n'ont pas
mis à la disposition des chercheurs par
exemple cette façon de faire de manière
quasiment autocratique
elle va se payer en 2022 et ses
stratégies à long terme
elle est catastrophique pour pour
la majorité je pense que certains en
sont conscients vous avez de plus en
plus de défections du parti la
république en marche de gens qui sont
déçus qu'ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
on fait cette pratique là alors que la
promesse était celle d'un nouveau monde
démocratique
donc il y a une vraiment une vision de
court terme de dire finalement on est là
pour faire le sale boulot et puis après
on verra bien alors on débat beaucoup
autour de la forme un peu moins autour
du fond est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer très brièvement à qui va
profiter cette réforme ce système
universel par points que veut mettre en
place des exécutifs alors de l'avis de
l'exécutif ce système serait plus juste
et bénéficierait au moins dotées
actuellement donc les femmes seules les
gens qui avaient des petites retraites
moins de 1000 euros or les lois existent
déjà on pourrait déjà avoir des
retraites à 1000 euros
et il se trouve que ce régime universel
en fait n'existera pas puisqu'on va
faire non plus des régimes spéciaux mais
des du cas par cas avec ce qui met des
régimes spéciaux à bécon en fait on fait
de la novlangue on change un peu les
termes mais en revanche pour la majorité
des français
et ça je pense que tout le monde est
conscient et c'est pour ça qu'une telle
mobilisation
ça veut dire un allongement de la durée
du travail on parle maintenant d'un âge
pivot à 65 ans et non plus 64 ans dans
les faits et une baisse tout simplement
des pensions de retraites avec en plus
là où on avait 14 % du pib qui était
destiné à faire retraite dans le système
que nous avons par répartition est bien
avec la baisse des cotisations des
salaires de plus de 10000 euros
vous avez en réalité un manque à gagner
de plusieurs milliards d'euros qui fait
qu' on sera sur une base de 13 % du pib
avec un nombre de retraités qui va
augmenter
donc on est en train de préparer la
paupérisation de la retraite solidaire
pour mettre en place ce système par
épargne retraite
blackrock mais dax à b et c on voit en
ce moment tout le secteur et la banque
assurance est en ébullition parce que
cette réforme est faite pour eux parce
que cette réforme est faite pour faire
des économies au budget de l'état tout
simplement il n'est pas question ici de
bien-être des français ou de préparer la
solidarité ou la pérennité du système de
retraites il est question de faire de
l'argent pour le secteur privé de la
finance et de faire des économies pour
l'état
voilà c'est ça c'est quasiment avoué on
ne la voulez pas au début avec le
rapport de le voit depuis quelques
semaines c'est quasiment avoué c'est
quasiment officiel et c'est bien pour ça
que la mobilisation est bien ne se tarit
pas merci monsieur poulin d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur et cofondateur du monde
moderne merci